we're in the first third of the pride
half year what and the corporations are
reminding us of this because their
commercials are rainbow colored and I am
going to try to guess
what product they are selling
[Music]
are they smoking
or are they gay
[Music]
that's really great
that's really great my producer Mr
Davies is telling me these these are not
actual pride month commercials these are
the commercials that will not be allowed
to be played during pride month probably
a little more blunt maybe a little more
truthful in some cases
and so I've got to pick my my favorite
that's a really strong strong Contender
let's see number two
[Music]
it's an actual Bud Light commercial who
are you calling guys yeah looks like
you're in the finals
for the great taste that won't fill you
up and never let you down make it a Bud
Light you're the defending ladies pool
champion
yes I am
Bud Light which is now just full-on
transheiser bush
as pro-lgbt Elemental fees it can
possibly be Bud Light used to have a
commercial mocking at least the T of all
of this if not the whole rainbow it's a
real Pride Commercial by a real prideful
company that now could not be played at
any time of the year how far we have
fallen next one the high life is tied of
a bunch of Superfly overpaid athletes
getting all the sponsorships just do it
so we're sponsoring real folks instead
D'Angelo Billy what's happening Miller
how life wants to be the official beer
youth here's your contract oh that's
cool Ricky Wilcox Miller High Life wants
to be the official beer you and your
vehicle modifications three more miles a
gallon thanks for living the Highlight
bubble
2011 this was not that long ago that we
could still make fun of sexual
eccentricity and cross-dressing and all
the rest of it
oh and what's funny now is sometimes
Libs will go back and they'll find
conservative institutions or people or
programs or companies that have
previously featured or participated in
some kind of drag joke and they'll say
haha see you support genderism you're a
big hypocrite oh you dirty boy no it
used to be a joke cross-dressing has
figured into theater for all of human
history
it was a joke the problem now is that
it's not taken as a joke it's taken
seriously and so you can't even if these
companies wanted to hear these
commercials now they couldn't because
you'd have a committed group of
activists with their arms crossing
that's that's not funny stop that Miller
and Bud Light him and every company
until like five minutes ago next one
all right
what are those
ah dang man should act like men and
Light beer should taste like beer
Milwaukee's best life Milwaukee's based
flight
I like it hmm hmm do we know who owns
Milwaukee's based because I might I
don't really like any beer are you
serious listen I'm more of a flavored
hard Seltzer guy you are gay which is
why I never need to worry about my
drinks going because they're already so
gay that they've got their pride
bonifides okay and I as an American
red-blooded man don't need to worry
about them going further down the
decadent rabbit hole but I'll I'll start
drinking Milwaukee's base if it's not
owned by size or something like that
right now go to expressvpn.com Michael
YT it is extremely important to protect
your online privacy with the VPN
choosing a VPN that you trust
equally important I can say with full
confidence that expressvpn is the best
VPN on the market here is why number one
expressvpn doesn't log your online
activity they've even developed a
trusted server technology that makes it
impossible for their servers to store
any data at all
2. speed expressvpn does not slow down
your user experience you can even stream
HD videos with zero buffering number
three expressvpn is incredibly easy to
use just fire up the app and tap one
button to connect it's not just me
saying this Business Insider The Verge
many other Tech journals rate expressvpn
the number one VPN in the world protect
yourself with the VPN that I trust use
my link expressvpn.com Michael YT today
get three months free in a one year
package
expresvpn.com Michael YT letter y letter
T expressvpn.com Michael YT head on over
there today
what's the next one uh light beer please
sure do you care how it tastes no I
don't care about this okay well when you
start caring put down your purse and
I'll give you a Miller Lite
it's a carry-all no it's not man up
because if you're drinking a light beer
without great pilsner taste you're
missing the point of drinking beer grab
a triple hubs brewed Miller Lite taste
greatness I'm gonna get him another way
I watch your purse
it's intario this is a reminder too that
part of the way that we ended up in our
bizarre androgynous culture is not just
because men have gone soft but because
women have allowed men to go soft women
traditionally have played an important
role in society
forcing men to man up think of that
scene in
some kind of old Gladiator type movie
the wife was there his husband goes off
they say come back with your Shield or
on it
yeah you're gonna toughen up or I think
of sweet little Elisa one time I had to
kill a cockroach and I really don't like
cockroaches we had this huge like the
biggest cockroach you ever saw and it
was a little bit squeamish about going
after the Cockroach Lisa said Mac you
got a man up you gotta get over there
you gotta just go up there to go grab
the Cockroaches crazy cockroach I
thought you're right she's right I do I
got you got a man up sometimes
next one
doesn't Miller Light taste great yeah
but I drink it because it's less filling
great taste
[Music]
oh man now that would make a great
commercial who wouldn't want to watch
that life is best told over a great
tasting Miller Lite at a place called
Miller time
[Music]
it's a great commercial for many reasons
we'll be about jugsy nipple chesty melon
but in part because it's selling the
beer to both men and women it opens up
right the women are saying we love
Miller Light and I love it for this
reason I love it for this reason and
then it cuts back and it says these are
the men just thinking about this the men
really like Miller like they're drinking
it and sharing it and they're sharing it
in real life with these women and so it
really checks a lot of boxes for
advertising I'm very impressed by Miller
Lite they've got a disproportionate
number of these very very basic
commercials
okay what's my favorite one I'm not
gonna say my favorite one because I
aspire to Virtue and I don't want to
have to answer to my wife for saying my
favorite one actually my favorite one
you know beyond any sort of appeals to
prurian interest is the first one that
he's smoking they gay and what is the
least likely to be played now I know I
guess the drag one probably that's the
least likely one to be played and then
that would be followed by the wet
t-shirt mud wrestling one because
that involves men and women behaving in
a normal way well I guess mud wrestling
Between Women is not exactly normal but
that that being a male fantasy is normal
and it involves very attractive people
and in advertising now we're not no
longer allowed to have Attractive people
we have to have the most intentionally
practiced grotesque kind of looking
people possible not even just naturally
grotesque they make themselves look
grotesque because we're a society that
worships ugliness I'm Michael knows this
the Michael Knowles show see you next
time
it's July 1st